-So one thing we were talkin
about recently at the show
is how people always make
such a big deal about babies
who are born on a special date
or special time.
You know, the first baby
of the new year,
the first baby of the
new millennium, you know?
If there's a baby born at 11:1
on 11/11.
But we realized you never
check back in with them.
You know, you talk about i
when they're born
and then never again --
until now.
We're really excited
about this.
Please welcome Bryce Tinsley
a baby born exactly at 8:00 A.M.
on 08/08/88.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How are you?
[ Applause ]
So, Bryce, thank you so much
for making the time.
You, for a moment,
were a very famous baby.
You were born on 08/08/88.
I mean, that must have bee
awesome.
-Yeah, it's every man's dream,
peaking at age zero.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know, they do say
it's supposed to be good luck.
Have you found that to be
the case?
-Oh, kind of the exact opposite.
I think I'm the first baby whose
dad died in childbirth.
-Oh, wait,
how did your dad --
You know, I don't want
to hear it.
-Neither did the local paper
-Yeah, um...
So you're saying your specia
birthday has been bad luck
-I mean, it hasn't been
all bad luck.
Like just this morning
I was on the subway and --
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues,
applause ]
Ow.
-Ow?
Just ow? A studio light
fell on your head.
-I'm -- I'm fine.
I'm glad it was just
a studio light this time.
-Well, I mean, I'm pretty sure
you have a lawsuit
on your hands.
-Oh, no, no, Seth, please do not
sue me for breaking your light
I just finished settling
with that restaurant
that gave me hepatitis.
-No, no, no, no. I meant -
[ Laughter ]
I meant that you would
be the plaintiff.
-Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Jurors say I have defendan
face, whatever that means.
-Yeah.
It's fine though, I'm just -
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God, another light
-This stinks.
-Do you --
Do you need anything,
Bryce?
Can I get you anything?
-No, I just need a drink.
-Okay. Great.
-Is this water?
I'm allergic to water!
-You're allergic to water?
-Oh, you know what, it's fine.
I have like 20 minutes
till something bad happens
-Oh, my God.
Well, man, this is really proo
that being born on 08/88
does not sound like
it's as blessed a birthday
as everyone would say.
-Ah, I mean, it's not all bad.
I got my picture in the paper.
-Yeah, that's right. We actually
have the paper right here.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what that says?
-Wait, you never read
this article?
-I was a baby when it came out
-Yeah, I guess that's --
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Groaning ]
-I cannot tell you
how sorry I am about this,
Bryce.
-It's fine.
Comedy comes in threes, so..
-Yeah, that's true, so you'r
probably safe. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-A fourth one?
-A fourth one.
This is Bryce Tinsley,
the not so lucky born --
born on 08/08/88, everyone
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I stay here tonight?
-No!
-Please!
-We'll be right back, everybody.
-I have nowhere to go.